je vous parlais il y a quelques jours du
A54 5G qui est le smartphone le plus
haut de gamme dans le milieu game je
vous ai également parlé du A34 5G qui
est le smartphone qui se situe un peu
dans le milieu du milieu de gamme on va
se parler aujourd'hui du A14 5G qui lui
est plus dans l'entrée du milieu de
gamme alors ce à 14,5 g il est
intéressant hop là pourquoi et bien
parce que à la base samsung vous propose
deux versions du A14 une version 4G une
version 5G sur la version 4G vous allez
avoir un médiathèque un Eliot G80 tandis
que sur la version 5G on va monter avec
un DM City 700 et c'est justement ce
smartphone là dont on va parler
aujourd'hui alors est-ce que ce Galaxy
A14 5G est intéressant au niveau de la
performance au niveau des photos au
niveau de la réactivité au niveau de
l'expérience logiciel on va regarder un
petit peu tout ça on va regarder
également s'il est bien au niveau du
divertissement au niveau de l'écran
est-ce que l'écran est de bonne qualité
est-ce qu'on a envie de passer du temps
dessus c'est vraiment le sujet qui va
nous arrêter aujourd'hui pour tout
savoir sur ce smartphone et bien
évidemment s'il vous intéresse je vous
mets un lien juste en bas dans la
description pour le trouver dans les
meilleures conditions tout en sachant en
plus que si vous l'achetez jusqu'au 30
avril vous avez des Galaxy buds 2 offert
ça c'est plutôt chouette une fois de
plus t'es rien d'affiliation que je vous
mets en bas dans la description vous
êtes prêts allez c'est parti
ces trois nouveaux smartphones se
ressemblent énormément ils ont tous les
trois le design qu'on va venir retrouver
sur les galaxies S23 cette année avec
cette caméra qui vient légèrement
déborder un peu sur le côté ça c'est
assez joli parce que donne une vraie une
uniformisation au niveau de la gamme
entre le A14 le A34 et le A54 et bien
évidemment on se parle ici du A14 5G
pour autant même si ces trois
smartphones se ressemblent à l'intérieur
c'est vraiment totalement différent
regardez autant sur les deux autres
smartphones vous avez une dalle Super
AMOLED autant ici vous êtes sur une
dalle TFT et au-delà même de cette dalle
TFT on voit déjà que le design n'est pas
le même c'est-à-dire que vous avez ici
une petite bulle en haut dans laquelle
va être planqué votre caméra de selfie
vous avez un grand menton les bords sont
aussi assez large donc c'est pas le
smartphone qui aura les bordures les
plus fines au monde pour autant Samsung
ici via s'adresser au primo-accédant
c'est à dire un public plutôt jeune
premier smartphone probablement aux
alentours de 13 14 ans d'ailleurs je
sais pas si c'est votre cas dites-le moi
dans les commentaires il est néanmoins
plutôt bien fabriqué alors un petit peu
épais là sur le côté mais la prise en
main pas mauvaise c'est pas là où on va
voir la meilleure prison mais attention
mais néanmoins le taf est fait alors
différence également par rapport aux
deux autres modèles vous avez le capteur
d'empreintes digitale sur le côté vous
posez votre doigt ça déverrouille
rapidement donc ça c'est plutôt très
très bien on le trouve très bien il est
pas mal positionné alors si vous le
prenez un peu sur le bas peut-être qu'il
a un petit peu haut vaut mieux le
prendre comme ça pour venir le retrouver
et ça fonctionne vous avez vos petits
boutons de volume sur le haut et après
sur le reste du smartphone pas grand
chose si ce n'est votre tiroir de carte
SIM qui vient se trouver ici de l'autre
côté alors je vous en parlais de cette
dalle cette dalle TFT je sais pas si ça
vous parle et bien c'est une dalle qui
n'est pas mal mais qui n'est pas non
plus la meilleure Samsung est très connu
pour ces dalles Super AMOLED pour son
AMOLED son dynamique à Molay 2x là on
est vraiment dans le très haut de gamme
dans l'entrée de gamme ils ont conservé
ici une dalle TFT alors on se parle dans
le grand écran c'est du 6,6 pouces ça
c'est plutôt bien mais en terme de
colorimétrie je vais pas la trouver
folle folle et vous avez pas grand chose
à venir faire dessus après c'est à dire
que vous pouvez venir mettre un confort
visuel mais je trouve ça pas fou les
couleurs sont pas très jolies peut-être
plus reposant mais pas extrêmement jolie
alors à ce moment-là vous le mettez
comme ça et vous venez vraiment le
baisser je veux dire hop là juste ici ça
sera un petit peu peu moins blanc ça
peut être intéressant pour vous voyez
vous venez le mettre là à peu près par
ici au niveau de la température de
couleur ça vient le réchauffer un peu
après vous avez le choix au niveau de la
fluidité des mouvements soit vous
laissez monter jusqu'en 90 Hertz soit
vous laissez en 60 hertz et là c'est
l'adaptatif il va venir switcher
automatiquement bon c'est assez malin la
résolution est convenable correcte c'est
du full HD+ ok donc ici pas de mauvaise
surprise et une fois de plus on t'arrive
de 249 € ça me semble assez cohérent
autre particularité à venir connaitre si
vous voulez regarder du contenu
directement sur votre smartphone ici
vous avez uniquement des haut-parleurs
mono 1 haut par leur mono d'ailleurs pas
dé haut-parleurs mais un haut-parleur
mono qui se situe juste ici vous n'avez
pas deuxième haut-parleur alors spoiler
à l'air je vous le dis le son est assez
médium c'est pas extraordinaire à venir
écouter comme ça il y a une asymétrie du
fait d'avoir juste un haut-parleur sur
le côté et le son est pas foufou d'où
l'intérêt ça peut être intéressant pour
vous si vous intéresse et bien de
l'avoir avec ses Galaxy buds 2 je vous
dis les précommandes font jusqu'au 30
avril et ça peut être pas mal parce que
c'est là où vous aurez la meilleure
expérience pour venir regarder du
contenu multimédia ici dessus alors
après il y a un autre point qui est bien
vous avez ici vous n'avez pas sur les
autres c'est qu'ils ont conservé la
prise donc si vous voulez venir brancher
un casque ici et bien vous pouvez le
faire en filaire donc ça c'est pas mal
aussi et je vous le dis une fois de plus
vous n'avez pas cette prise directe sur
les A34 et à 54 ici ah ce processeur ce
processeur qu'est-ce qu'il raconte
est-ce que ce médiathèque d'emmène City
700 est intéressant alors bon autant je
fais tourner des jeux autant je me suis
amusé sur asphalt 9 ça fonctionne autant
je trouve pas très réactif quand il
s'agit de faire de la photo je vous
montre je me mets ici par exemple et je
me mets sur mon mode photo un peu
standard on va venir zoomer vous allez
voir et là je vais venir changer au
niveau de mes optiques donc là hop là
regardez je vais me mettre ça par ici
histoire que vous voyez donc là je suis
là et alors déjà j'ai pas de d'ultra
grand-angle ici je vais avoir uniquement
une caméra portrait mais on en parle
dans quelques instants et là je vais
venir switcher donc je passe sur mon X-2
ça marche et dès que je passe sur le X 4
vous voyez j'appuie x 4 x 10 et ben je
trouve ça pas très réactif alors ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet Bonnel
dit je vous le montre là ça marche tout
à l'heure je le faisais en plein jour il
fallait que j'appuie deux trois fois
vous voyez là des fois pour passer du x
4 x 10 et bien il faut un petit peu
aller le chercher et je trouvais que
c'était un peu la limite c'est que des
fois ça répond pas très bien alors là ça
répond beaucoup plus vite mais si vous
regardez bien des fois ça fonctionne un
peu moins bien là il faut un je l'ai pas
eu donc c'est un peu la limite des
3 et bien vous aurez une grosse batterie
de 5000 millions par heure et ça c'est
cool et alors la différence ici que vous
allez avoir avec celui là par rapport
aux autres c'est qu'ici vous n'allez pas
avoir de la recharge 25 watts vous aurez
de la recharge uniquement 15 watts ça
n'a pas la charge la plus rapide pour
venir recharger une très grosse batterie
de 5000 milliampères heure donc il va
falloir s'armer de patience si vous
voulez venir recharger votre smartphone
autre point de différence également qui
est vraiment important à venir connaître
c'est que là où sont les deux autres
smartphones sur le A34 5g et le A54 5G
bien vous avez 4 ans de mise à jour
Android et 50 mise à jour sécurité et
bien sur ce A14 5G vous avez deux ans de
mise à jour Android donc Android 14
Android 15 pas plus et 4 ans de mise à
jour de sécurité ça c'est pas mal et
maintenant l'autre point qui va venir
vraiment nous intéresser
c'est quoi capteurs ici vous n'avez pas
trois caméras intéressantes loin de là
vous avez une caméra grand angle de 50
mégapixels ok on se dit c'est pas mal
mais maintenant cette caméra grand angle
de 50 mégapixels elle a un inconvénient
c'est qu'elle n'a aucune stabilisation
et si vous me prenez moi par exemple
avec mon tremblement essentiel ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que ça bouge ça
bouge et ça bouge beaucoup je sais pas
si vous allez bien vous en rendre compte
là mais lorsque je l'ai appelé pour
faire des photos il y a des moments j'ai
franchement galéré et c'est pas un truc
que je viens vous recommander alors
autant sur la version 4G et bien vous
avez un ultra grand-angle autant sur la
version 5G vous avez une caméra portrait
pourquoi une caméra portrait de 2
mégapixels
les parents qui vont venir acheter ce
smartphone là et une fois de plus est-ce
qu'on a envie de mettre un smartphone à
500 balles dans les mains de son enfant
qui va avoir un premier smartphone j'en
suis globalement pas convaincu donc le
taf est fait on a des souvenirs c'est
corrects pour avoir un premier
smartphone c'est bien mais c'est vrai
que vous allez voir que rapidement on va
être limité au niveau de la qualité de
photo et ça va pas être dingue quand on
veut venir zoomer après on sort quand
même quelques souvenirs qui peuvent être
pas mal lors de virer entre potes ça
peut fonctionner et être pas dégueu la
voyez je n'ai pas de stabilisation avec
le tremblement ça m'a débloqué cette
fleur et c'était très particulier mais
bon on peut quand même sortir des
souvenirs on va pas chercher un truc de
fou mais on sent quelques souvenirs et
c'est à relativement intéressant alors
la caméra de selfie elle est aussi un
petit peu de mal au niveau de la gestion
de haute lumière le soleil tape fort et
très très fort je suis complètement
cramé sur la gueule faut le dire là ça a
été ça s'en est pas trop trop mal sorti
là ça a été à peu près mais attention
votre lumière la voyez sur le haut là il
a eu beaucoup de mal au niveau des
hautes lumières et sur cette espèce de
contre-jour bon voilà il bricole un truc
mais on voit qu'il a un petit peu de mal
alors la macro une fois de plus c'est
pareil on peut faire des petits
souvenirs je ne suis pas du tout façon
convaincu que en achetant ce smartphone
en face beaucoup une petite photo au
niveau de la macro mais si vous
souhaitez vous pouvez le faire par
contre les modes portrait m'a assez
surpris voyez ici l'éclairage est très
maîtrisé c'est exactement ici avec le
même random que j'ai au dessus mais le
rendu est globalement pas mauvais et je
trouve ça plutôt bien alors il galère
par moment un petit peu à détourer dans
certains endroits mais dans l'absolu le
boulot n'est pas dégueulasse ici alors
ici il me cherchait pas de certification
IP quelque chose ne me cherchez pas de
vercornig Aurillac quelque chose il y en
a pas Samsung ici est vraiment venu
faire de l'économie pour vous proposer
un tarif bien positionné donc ça c'est
pas mal le petit truc c'est qu'on sent
vraiment le côté un petit peu plastique
sous le doigt on le sent un petit peu
léger on sent qu'à l'intérieur vous
voyez on se dit tiens il paraît un peu
moins costaud que ce qu'on a notamment
si vous prenez le à 34 qui paraîtra un
peu plus costaud il y a vraiment une
différence en terme de prise en main
mais une fois de plus dans ce tarif là
bon ça me paraît pas surprenant truc qui
est assez sympa par contre c'est que ils
vous ont fait un espèce de petite
matière où on sent vraiment sous le
doigt vous voyez il y a un côté avec des
espèces de petites lignes qu'on sent pas
mal on voit bien également il y a un
petit relief au niveau du branding
Samsung ici qui est pas mal c'est assez
joli en fait ça fonctionne bien donc ça
c'est assez cool si vous comparez par
rapport à 54 qui lui est en vert qui est
très très lisse ou un à 34 qui lui est
en plastique est très lisse c'est pas
mal alors après il y en a pour tous les
groupes peut-être que vous aimerez ou
peut-être que vous aimerez pas mais
écoutez le bruit
une espèce de rap à fromage pour votre
doigt mais ça peut être marrant pourquoi
pas pour enlever des peaux mortes allez
savoir alors soyons clairs le A14 5G
n'est pas le smartphone qu'on va acheter
sur un coup de cœur en se disant j'adore
ce qu'il y a dans le ventre j'adore ce
qu'il propose je veux absolument un 14
5g et comme me disait quelqu'un qui
bossait chez Wiko avant c'est plus sur
smartphone qu'on va venir subir plutôt
qu'on va venir acheter soyons clairs
mais pour autant pour quelqu'un qui veut
acheter un premier smartphone et à qui
on va acheter un premier smartphone et
bien il est pas mal et le truc qui est
intéressant surtout c'est que vous êtes
dans l'expérience Samsung avec One uye
donc si vous intéressez à Samsung et si
vous aimez l'écosystème commencez à
mettre un pied ici dans One uey ça peut
être pas mal l'expérience logiciel elle
est très claire très lisible le taf est
bien fait au niveau des icônes bref je
trouve ça bien fait j'aime bien cette
expérience Manua il se trouve très cool
très sexy donc vous pouvez prendre vos
repères ici puis plus tard peut-être
quand il sera temps de changer de
smartphone ou de monter en gamme et bien
vous aurez déjà vos repères bon voilà 6
points de détails ce à 14 5G disponible
je vous l'ai dit à 149 euros et puis
n'oubliez pas s'il vous intéresse vous
avez une offre de lancement qui va
jusqu'au 30 avril 2023 avec des galaxies
buds 2 offert ça c'est plutôt pas mal
une fois de plus je vous mets les liens
juste en bas dans la description allez
puis dites-moi ce que vous en pensez de
ce smartphone il est correct il est pas
foufou mais il fera le taf ça peut être
un résumé correct pas fou mais il fera
top dites-moi ce que vous en pensez en
bas dans les commentaires puis nous on
se retrouve très bientôt bien évidemment
pour continuer à parler tech donc d'ici
là prenez soin de vous je vous embrasse
et puis beaucoup d'amour gros bisous
Ciao